اي بي سي بمقتل تسعة جنود
امريكيين جراء تحطم مروحيتين في
بموقف بكين حيال حرب بوتين في
اوكرانيا. اي انهم يطلبون
الاجابة من وزارة الدفاع الصينية
التي اعلنت ان الجيش الصيني على
سيتعاونان في تنفيذ مبادرات
امنية عالمية. فعن اي مبادرات
البقية يعملون بكل راحة يا
اصدقاء اما في الغرب فحتى دولة
الحروب كبعضها ورب حرب قد تعيد
احد اطرافها عشرات السنين الى
روسيا تزيد من ضغطها على
الولايات المتحدة والامريكان
اندونيسيا من حق استضافة بطولة
كأس العالم للشباب. افادت قناة
التدريب. فماذا لو دخلت امريكا
حربا حقيقية؟ كيف سيكون حالها؟
تقرير بريطاني ان روسيا جندت
شبكة جواسيس وعملاء سريين في
وزير الدفاع البريطاني ان دبابات
البريطانية وصلت الى اوكرانيا.
طالما وجد في السلطة. مؤكدا
بلاده مستعدة للوساطة بين كييف
تعويض طهران عن ذلك فكيف سترد
واشنطن توتر غير مسبوق في
التي لا تنتمي للبنك المركزي
الايراني. ويتعين على واشنطن
العسكري الروسي ان مجموعة فاغنر
تواصل عملياتها الهجومية للسيطرة
المشتركة الذي حذر انه في حال
اندلاع حرب بين المتحدة واي قوة
الذخيرة. وقال ان عليهم النظر في
حرب اوكرانيا وهي في الحقيقة حرب
اقليمية محدودة وفق قوله.
مخزوناتكم تنضب يا ابناء العم
الكبرى على الامريكيين بلسان
رئيس هيئة الاركان الامريكية
بوضوح يا ميدفيديف. ان العالم
سيتطور بدون الولايات المتحدة
سام. فماذا انتم فاعلون? حروب
الروس مع الامريكان لا تنسيهم
بنجاح دون صراخ الغرب ودون فرض
مسار التنمية عليها. فلتقلها
المتحدة. حيث قال وزير الخارجية
الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان روسيا
ينتقل الروس الى القارة
الامريكية بالقرب من الولايات
ستأتيهم الضربة القادمة. فها هي
محكمة ليفورتوفو شرقي العاصمة
كوفيتش مراسل صحيفة وول ستريت
جورنال الامريكي في قضية تجسس.
في العلن. والطباخ بوتين يعلن عن
استخدام استراتيجية الارض
المحروقة وموسكو تعتقل جاسوسا
امريكيا متلبسا بجرمه. فكيف سترد
واشنطن والدبابات البريطانية تصل
الى الاراضي الاوكرانية. فهل
يتحدث الاحداث والتطورات. قضت
محكمة العدل الدولية بان
متابعينا. هل تعترفون باسرائيل
كدولة مستقلة? وجهت الجامعة
لكن ماذا عن الطرف الاخر لتأتي
الاجابة من الجنرال ديفيد برجر
لكن بن والا صعد ليحبط
الاوكرانيين بقوله انه لا يزال
ولاية كنتاكي الامريكية سقطت هذه
المقاتلات الامريكية اثناء
فهل تفعلها بكين? سنترك الاجابة
لاصحاب العيون الضيقة. لتأتي
طحينا وبعد رفضها مشاركة الكيان
الاسرائيلي. الفيفا يجرد
يتخبطون بردود افعالهم؟ بينما
التنين الصيني لا يرحم؟ هل
العاشرة من العقوبات التي فرضها
الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد روسيا على
على القارة الاوروبية. هنا قالت
رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية ان
مستقبل العلاقة بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي مرهون بدرجة كبيرة
وبطريقة غير مباشرة ان تتوسط
بكين لايقاف الحرب الاوكرانية.
المحروقة رغم الحاقها ضررا بالغا
بقواته. بينما اعلن موقع ريبار
اخرى في علم الولايات المتحدة
وفق قوله. سنترك الاجابة لكم
الولايات المتحدة جمدت بشكل غير
قانوني جزءا من الاصول الايرانية
وايديس مشاة البحرية الامريكية.
الذي اكد ان قواته تفتقر الى
العربية دعوة الى دولي بخصوص
اتخاذ خطوات جادة وحقيقية لانهاء
العلاقات الامريكية الاسرائيلية.
حيث قال وزير الامن القومي
والذي شدد على انه لن يسمح للغرب
بجر بلاده الى حرب ضد روسيا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للاراضي
الفلسطينية. نسمع جعجعة على نرى
كما هو مخطط لها في اوكرانيا.
ولا شيء متروك للحظ حيث افاد
لسويسرا وابتعادها عن مبدأ
الحياد في اتصالاتها مع الناتو.
هناك طريق طويل قبل استخدامها في
المعارك. في اشارة لعمليات
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن خفير ان
اسرائيل دولة مستقلة وليست نجمة
فاجن يقول ان معركة مدينة باخموت
دمرت الجيش الاوكراني باستخدام
لتعلن مواجهة الدب الروسي؟
امريكا تعترف للصين؟ ليست جميع
نيوز ويك. بل هو اعلان سابق
للهزيمة الامريكية ليأتي الدور
خلفية حرب اوكرانيا. لتعود ماريا
زاخاروفا وتتصدر المشهد وترد
استعداد للعمل مع الجيش الروسي
لتعزيز الاتصال والتنسيق
ونحن نعلم ان لا تمتلك جيشا
ليحميها. فما الذي تعتمد عليه
الوراء. وهذه الحرب حتما سيكون
احد اطرافها هو التنين الصيني،
الاستراتيجي. ليقول المتحدث باسم
وزارة الدفاع الصينية ان البلدين
اوكرانيا قبل الحرب. وقد اعتقلت
كييف الالاف منهم، لكن يبدو ان
قدرة رئيسية يمكن ان تكون حاسمة
في ردع صراع مع الصين او في شن
بقولها ان موسكو ستأخذ في
الاعتبار الاجراءات الاضافية
معركتهم الاصلية في اوكرانيا.
هنا طباخ بوتين ومؤسس مجموعة
الامريكية. اوليس هذا ما اردت
قوله يا هذا؟ لتأتي الطامة
ايفانوف ان واشنطن لم تتواصل بعد
مع بشأن الصحفي الامريكي المعتقل
وموسكو في اقرب وقت. لكن موسكو
لا تنتظر الوساطة وتسير معاركها
فورا. لترد المتحدثة الرسمية
باسم وزارة الخارجية الروسية
حرب بنجاح اذا اندلعت مثل هذه
الحرب في المحيط الهادئ بحسب
على الشمال الغربي لباخموت.
لتأتي جرعة امل لكييف باعلان
الحياد في العالم سويسرا قد كسرت
حيادها. وانضمت الى الحزمة
الروسية موسكو تصدر امر اعتقال
بحق الصحفي الامريكي ايفان جيرش
التدريب. ليظهر في الطرف الاخر
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوجان.
عدة استراتيجيات ومنها ما لا
يقارن باستراتيجية الارض
كبرى في العالم فان هذا النزاع
سيستنفذ مخزونات هائلة من
والفيفا يعاقب اندونيسيا والسبب
اسرائيل. موسكو تطلق سهامها.
الامن سيد ميتري ميدفيديف بان
دول العالم يمكنها ان تتطور
يتودد. وجامعة العرب تتخذ قرارا
مهما للقضية الفلسطينية. نسمع
مدينة كاترينبورج لا علاقة له
بالصحافة. فما الذي كان يفعله
بتهمة التجسس. ضربات موسكو
تتوالى على واشنطن. وهذه المرة
هذا الصحفي اذا? هنا يؤكد نائب
وزير الخارجية الروسي جيني
سيكا. منوها بان الاتفاقية بخصوص
ذلك جاهزة. ليصرح نائب رئيس مجلس
ستحصل قريبا على وضع مراقب في
منظومة التكامل لامريكا الوسطى
ماريا زاخاروفا ان ما كان يفعله
مراسل الصحيفة الامريكية في
يحتمل ويوشك ان ينكسر.
والامريكان لا يعلمون من اين
بعد ان كانت قد تحرشت ببوتين.
فهل انقلب السحر على الساحر
وول ستريت جورنال نفت الموجهة
لصحفيها وطالبت بالافراج عنه
جعجعة ولا نرى طحينا والمحكمة
الجنائية الدولية تتحرش بواشنطن
السهام تتساقط نحو الولايات
المتحدة. والدرع الامريكي لا
لن نسمح للغرب بجرنا الى حرب ضد
روسيا. هكذا فجرها الرئيس التركي
امام الصين صيني يتحضر للانضمام
لنظيره الروسي والاتحاد الاوروبي
سيفي بوتين بوعده? بينما
الولايات المتحدة تعترف بعجزها
اقتربت امريكا من ترك دفة
القيادة لتتولى دولة اخرى